you have a new HBO show the brink and in
it you play United States Secretary of
State and and I'm wondering what
appealed to you about this role you get
to play this guy who's got a lot of
power yeah what appealed to me was the
the script you know it was really sharp
smart satire which is rare to find and
you know I understood before I read the
script that I was going to be playing
the United States Secretary of State and
then I read the first scene that he's in
and he's he's with an asian hooker in a
Washington DC hotel room I think we have
a still from hack he's tied up and
role-playing thing with her and I
thought hmm so I'm pretty much in yeah
yes I'm doing this how much are you red
black is in the meeting friend for many
years right Jack Black as well so I
thought and a great team of writers and
aasif Mandvi is in it and he's terrific
and so I I just enjoyed myself
completely from beginning to end I
directed the second episode and was I
couldn't been happier are you gonna be
shirtless naked through a lot of this
series well let's put it this way he
Walter Larson has a very large appetite
for life and yeah yes then yeah so
almost every episode he's he's trying to
bed some woman yes yeah yeah while
dealing with a world crisis of course
you know right you know potential
nuclear war in Pakistan right the
writers were very they used kind of the
dr. Strangelove is a model that yes that
yes the situation has to be super
serious and and if we're going to find
the satire in it we have to remain true
to that but at the same time you be in
the course of the satire you see the
behavior is outrageous
yeah of these people that you would
think we're level-headed and
that we are entrusting are safe that's
kind of the lesson we keep learning
again and yes you think this guy holds
this high office or this person's a
senator or congressman there you know
and then of course they're not doing
that stuff no they they wouldn't be
diddling boys or anything like that like
this Dennis Hastert guy yeah that's and
it this part no I'm not yeah I know I
know but it's true it is it's true this
is a person a very high position who had
a lot of yoga credible or our a lot of
power and you would want you would want
those people to have some kind of moral
bottom line and oftentimes to our dismay
they don't and so you know this is part
of what we're satirizing in the brink
and trying to figure out a way to you
know it you you want to illuminate some
truth but you have to do it with humor
as you do as as everyone that approaches
entertainment tries to do yeah we're
gonna try it someday yeah already ease
into humor